ballerina gamers rejoice no longer
will you be one pumped with a bucky from
15 meters away
like you're playing fortnite riot games
just dropped a
massive new patch nerfing the bucky and
giving some
serious buffs to both yoru and viper
here's everything you need to know about
it
[Music]
alright guys you know that we've been
bringing you a ton
of valorant content lately and if you
guys want to see that keep happening
i need you to do me a favor i need you
to scroll down i need you to
absolutely annihilate that subscribe
button
and like the video alright so if you're
anything like me and you spend
way too much time after work right now
banging out games
of ranked valorum you know one thing for
certain
the bucky was too good this thing is
like
shotgun meets sniper rifle the range on
the right click is just
so long it's broken in half
as 10 seems to be showing us like every
other day for the last two months
this is free youtube content
yep
i think everybody who plays valor has
had a bucky tilt moment like this one
that subrosa had the other day
yeah i was left
[Music]
somehow the shotgun tilts me more than
reyna which at this point
is really saying something and the good
news about all this
is that riot finally nerfed it
on tuesday march 30th riot games
announced patch
2.06 for valerian which was set to knock
the bucky off of its half by
mantle as well as give some much needed
buffs
to two of the game's most
underrepresented ages
there's a lot in here so let's first go
over what they did to the bucky
quote we want to focus the bucky more on
its actual primary firing mode
left click and make that the strength
you try to optimize when choosing a
bucky versus alternate firing mode
right click the right click should be
more of a tool you use
when you can't get into that effective
left-click range or you just need some
reliable chip damage
the spreads are reduced on both to
increase reliability and smooth the
damage curve
the alt-fire's significant reduction in
pellet count is a trade-off to being
able to extend the range as much as it
does for a shotgun
end quote basically they want the bucky
to function more like a
shotgun so you're still going to be able
to get those left click
short range kills as intended but it
looks like the days of the 14
meter bucky one tap are over
which is a relief to rank players
everywhere
including hiko i think that the bucky
was broken for too long i think the
right quick was too good for too long
and i think this is a good change
let me make that clear i think this was
good i think it was needed and i think
people who bought
bought the bucky a lot uh are now gonna
either buy the shorty or they're only
they're gonna like exclusively block by
the
um the judge and i think on rounds that
they were gonna buy a bucky they're
gonna
instead buy either a shorty like i said
or they'll buy a sheriff or they'll buy
a ghost i don't think people will really
buy
the bucky anymore that said he did make
sure to get the broken bucky kills out
of his system
before the patch went live
i got mine that's all i know
now bear with me for a sec valerian and
cs go
die hards as i speak to the uninitiated
for a moment
because i think a lot of people are
probably asking themselves
the same questions when it comes to all
these pro players
complaining about shotguns why is the
bucky being good such a big deal
shouldn't other guns not just the rifles
be usable and the answer is
well yes and also no the thing is i
think it's
fine if riot wants a larger variety of
guns to be usable
than something like counter-strike where
basically the ak-47 the op
and the m4 reign supreme but the reality
is these games
tactical shooters are about rifles at
their core
and people love to watch these games
because those rifles are
so hard to play with and master and
what's not hard to master is stuffing
your barrel down somebody's face
in ropes on split or running and
spraying people with a stinger which
riot already had to fix
not too long ago which set a precedent
for this
change valrant has a run and gun problem
seriously if i get running sprayed by
the frenzy
or the stinger one more time i'm gonna
break my keyboard
so while i do think it's cute that in
this game sometimes it is right to buy a
judge or an aries or an odin over a
phantom
this bucky [ __ ] had to end and i'm
personally glad it's gone
now well the primary celebration
surrounding this patch was the bucky
getting the proverbial axe
riot also made some changes to the
game's two
worst agents yoru and viper let's start
with the toxin queen
herself my early perspective is that
this buff
is massive there are certainly a cult of
people in the valorant world that
love viper but so far in the game's
short history
she's been well pretty underwhelming
competitively but it looks like that
could be about to change here's what
riot said about the changes they made
quote when compared to other controllers
we want viper to make
big committed decisions that truly alter
the map
and how both sides plan around her
influence
she should claim ground with force and
dare opponents to challenge her
the updates to toxins should also
project more threat on enemies who
consider pushing her smoke
and will hopefully add a significant
bite to her murky toxic screen
paired with a couple other buffs and
some new tools for learning and
practicing lineups
we're excited to see if viper can
deliver on the deadly impact she
promises while solidifying her spot on
our roster end quote the biggest change
they made to viper was to herd decay
the amount of life you lose when you
walk into one of her toxins
you will now decay 50 life the second
you walk into toxic screen
poison cloud or her alt 50
that's a lot of life that's it boys we
don't push viper smokes anymore
i think the insta 50 decay is big and
maybe she'll start to be picked a lot
more i mean some teams are already
experimenting with her
on a more serious note it does seem just
that right has changed it so
for all intents and purposes you have to
have a
very good reason to walk through a viper
smoke which isn't true about
any other agent in the game so i'm down
for these changes
riot also got the scalpel out and did
some surgery on the game's newest agent
yoru now since his release yoru has been
mostly confusing he's a duelist but his
flash was clunky and takes forever to
activate
his tp is so loud and the whole thing
was just kind of a mess
and it led to basically nobody playing
him so right has made some significant
but small changes quote yoru carries a
fantasy that you've been excited to see
through
but we believe a few restrictions have
made it harder to access
although yoro is a unique duelist on the
roster both in pace and in playstyle
we think he should still be a strong
contender for good compositions
and want to ensure the value he offers
to his team is more consistent
throughout a match
end quote his flash now happens faster
and lasts longer
and his teleport ability no longer
re-ups on kills
it just comes back after 35 seconds
similar to sovis arrow or omen smokes
and you're also going to be able to use
that teleport ability while you're in
your ultimate
which makes yoru kind of a unique agent
right because
he's a dualist but you kind of want him
to hang around long enough
to re-up on his teleport ability which
is
exactly what hiko said i don't know if
he's like a duelist anymore right like
they're buffing his utility i feel like
now he has a lot of utility and as a
duelist
i feel like almost you don't want your
girl die anymore
because he gets this gate crash and
because it's a center it's like a 35
second interval synergy
hopefully buffing yoru in conjunction
with the similarities between his
teleport and jet's dash
means that one day we might see some pro
compositions using yoru
as an operator as well because we need
that bad
now that we're done with the agents
there's actually one more major change
coming in this patch that i haven't
mentioned yet
hrtf audio which is an insane acronym
but basically the sound's getting better
basically the cliff notes of it is you
can now hit escape go to your audio
settings and enable
hrtf audio which is going to improve
the spatial quality of your audio it's
going to be a little bit more of a 360
degree experience
you can hear people left right in front
and behind you a little better
so when there's a lurking jet ratting
near the tube on icebox
now you can hear her and kill her
instead of getting shot in the back of
the head
ryan tweeted out an example of the
change on tuesday
audio is of course a massive deal in
games like counter-strike
valerie and rainbow six and in my
opinion this might be the change from
this patch
that we remember the most in the long
run early reports seem to say that the
sound is
markedly better and the bucky does in
fact suck
and those are both dubs if you ask me
dude the sound is actually so good i can
actually hear you can hear the
difference in the stream dude it's
actually good
do you buy the boxer oh my god look
look at this there's literally only five
pellets
there's literally five pellets i mean i
think i
i basically think one a good way for you
to learn how to play valerian
is for you to just like unplug your
keyboard for the first 15 seconds of a
round
while everybody else is like waiting for
their utility
like figuring out where they are silva
darting
setting up like killjoy [ __ ] because
if they don't you're just like dead in
heaven
and and everyone's like not hasn't even
left spawn yet